dieser frauen wird auf dem schlachtfeld
meistens geopfert das tier hat keine
wahl
zieht der mensch auf das schlachtfeld
ist keine kreatur mehr sicher ohne
skrupel werden sie mit maschinen
bestückt werden teil der tödlichen pläne
tiere werden zu übermittlen zu
bombenlegern zu unfreiwilligen täter
guten
die junge autorin mal in gewinner
beschäftigt sich in ihrem ersten buch
mit den pelzigen und gefiederten
kriegsdienst lang in einem kurs an der
universität der künste in berlin
begegnet ihr zum ersten mal ein tier als
soldat ging es um die taube als metapher
für sichere datenübermittlung und der
wurde eingeleitet mit so einem bild von
einer taube die hatte vorne so eine
kamera umgeschnallt und ich fand dieses
bild einfach so verstörend weil es so
ungewohnt gewesen ist und hier zu sehen
was mit seiner maschine ausgerüstet ist
gewinner listet in ihrer enzyklopädie 33
rekrutierte tierarten auf mit funktion
und einsatzgebiet
die taube wird mit einer kamera
ausgerüstet zum spion
zuverlässig transportiert sie
botschaften zu den verbündeten und
sprengsätze in das gegnerische lager
oder trauben werden mit krankheiten
infiziert die sich später auf den
menschen übertragen
das us militär plant nach parabel
angriffe mit fledermaus bomben gegen
japan
in diesen speziellen behältern sollen
die tiere abgeworfen werden
delfine platzieren sprengsatz im kalten
krieg arbeiten als unterwasser aufklärer
und überwachen hafeneinfahrten
es findet immer eine heroisierung der
tiere statt
während des krieges und ich denke das
hängt damit zusammen dass soldaten und
tiere
sich in einer opfer gemeinschaft
wiederfinden tatsächlich acht millionen
menschen sterben auf deutscher seite
während des ersten weltkriegs und
ungefähr gleich viele pferde trotz
steigender technisierung werden tiere
exzessiv eingesetzt verbraucht
zeitgleich findet eine personalisierung
stadt tiere erhalten nahm sie werden zu
kameraden somit kämpfern auf augenhöhe
erhoben ich hab mich gefragt damit
zusammenhängt vor allem dass hier
menschen artig daher kommt die uniform
mit den zahlreichen auszeichnungen macht
aus einem pitbull terrier eine legende
stabil ist der höchstdekorierte rund des
ersten weltkriegs sogar der
amerikanische präsident wilson soll ihm
die pfote geschüttelt haben tapferkeit
einsatzwille und empathie menschliche
tugenden werdenden tier zugeschrieben
in dieser extremsituation sucht der
mensch sich selbst den tier momente in
denen die angst alle unterschiede
wegfegt
diese nähe zahlen die meisten tiere mit
ihrem leben die inschrift auf dem
kriegsdenkmal für tiere in london behält
ihre gültigkeit
sie hatten keine wahl